donald trump will never be president
again says renowned pollster frank luntz
this is a sydney morning herald won the
most one of the world's top holsters
frank luntz who has advised multiple
prop republican presidents says donald
trump will never never again
lead the united states he will not win
if trump wins again he will be nominated
by the republicans but he will never be
elected president because there are too
many people who hate him is what he says
and he continues
saying trump is the most popular
republican by far but he can't win a
general election because in the end
politics is about persona as much as it
is about policy and his persona is
unacceptable to too many people once has
worked as a strategist and poster for
the republican party for almost 30 years
and is regarded as one of the world's
most
incisive commentators so you obviously
agree with that right you don't think
you'll ever win
i think number one this guy do you know
who frank luntz is you want to pull him
up you've seen his face before
he
he this is what he does
like and he's uh he's works for the
republican party i want to say he might
say he's independent but this is what he
does i think it's a case of
if it were trump versus biden again and
again i don't even think biden should
run in four years it's almost like
unacceptable
versus unaware
there's 40 60 of the country that thinks
trump is unacceptable
i do not accept him
there's a large contingency in the
country that thinks biden is just
completely
helpless and unaware so this goes back
to my initial point
of are these our two best options is
this really where we're at right now can
we get a tulsi gabbard in there can we
get a desantis in there can we get a
rock in there is this really where we're
at that we're deciding again between
donald trump unacceptable versus biden
unaware so i'm saying and that came out
as an independent today and the climate
is perfect for the rock to win as an
independent i agree if if it's biden
trump on the left and the right and then
you got rock coming up the middle
i would vote for rock in a heartbeat
regardless of policy because what we've
established is that a lot of it is just
persona and therefore it's policy versus
persona in this scenario
where
you just explained it perfect i mean you
know you may not have the policies
initially as far as like the rock is
concerned but he has the persona that
oversees this like and people did not
vote for trump
enough because not because of the
policies it was because of the persona i
agreed so you know i
i got nothing
i got nothing no i was just saying him
could have been from 2015. i heard the
same crap leading up the hillary was
gonna win in a landslide and
listen i didn't vote for trump in uh 16
right and but all i heard everywhere was
this guy's got no chance the polls are
he's down by nine percent he's down by
twelve percent there's only three months
to go but there was something in the eye
test that everywhere i looked i didn't
see a single hillary lawn sign i didn't
see a single hillary banner i just saw
trump everywhere i was like this is odd
something about what i'm seeing day to
day driving around is different than
what i'm hearing on the news and every
pollster in the world came out and said
afterwards right 538 we need to readjust
our polls we didn't take this into
account we didn't take that in account
and then people want to act like he got
smoked in this last election he got more
votes he's the first president in the
history of the united states to get more
votes in his re-election campaign and
lose do you feel that some people now
are realizing that
policies
are important
yeah because of what is currently going
on in the world i think to a certain
degree that's a good point phil i also
think that i don't want him to run
because he activates the other side too
much i think desantis or somebody else
they don't have the vitriol that's going
to activate that extra five six percent
i think trump is going to activate
people that right now are completely
disenfranchised that are frankly
embarrassed that they supported biden i
know a lot of people that are
embarrassed that they they were like you
know what man orange man bad but maybe
it wasn't this bad my god right so many
people like that but
i believe
i will say that you do bring up a couple
of valid points and i and we you even
addressed this on rogan i don't think
that many people were voting because
they loved biden it's because trump was
that unacceptable and you said the
debated the other side if that meant man
well
um
people voted against trump not for biden
but
you said in 20 the difference between
2016 and 2020 is that he was an unproven
commodity at that point i don't know
this guy donald trump he's kind of in
there i don't know he's yeah he's crazy
he's doing some things i'll give him the
benefit of the doubt you know he'll
shake up washington by 2020 people knew
exactly what they were getting and
they're like i've seen this movie before
i know how this ends i do not want to
see the same movie for the fifth
freaking time i'm good let's see a new
movie even if the new movie sucks i've
seen that movie too many times i know
how it is so the pendulum now is on
policy probably no matter what i mean
i've chatted with a lot of different
people
um
black white everything and they've all
said that
policy is more important because of the
current economic climate and i think um
you take the name plates off
of candidates yeah i think we're gonna
realize that we live in a world where
man this person has a great persona but
these policies are great however yeah
with shows with social media and all
that stuff you've got to have both
brother you've got to tell you something
what percentage of americans actually
vote based on policy and policy i know
alone but when you're looking at 20
percent so what are the points right now
like they accepted small when you say
policy that's let's just define most
most voters vote on one issue single
issue voters make up over 70 votes so
there's no and it's not even necessarily
it's whatever benefits them yeah i mean
right
and single issue is what benefits them
yeah no it is but kai go ahead you were
trying to say something
kai we can't hear you i can okay now go
ahead uh for me a big thing as well as
we talked about with trump if the market
wouldn't have crashed
what are the odds that he would have
been reelected now can that can they
sustain that and push that out for
another two years if the market crashes
what are the odds biden can get elected
you're talking about covet not a market
crash no market crash no the market
crash was due to covet it's what you're
saying yeah what i'm saying is yeah also
that the the fact that that's now
bounced back in 13 months seems to be a
little bit propagated so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]